[Musica]
[Applauso]
chi non sa cos'è un deep fake avrete
certamente visto video di personaggi
noti che fanno dicono cose sorprendenti
video che sembrano autentici ma sono in
realtà realizzati mediante tecniche di
intelligenza artificiale
quella tecnologia ci permette di
modificare il volto l'espressione la
voce addirittura i movimenti del corpo
di una persona in questo video vi mostro
un filmato in cui tom cruise
interpreta iron man in realtà questo è
un deep fake e l'attore originale robert
downey è stato il volto di questo attore
è stato sostituito da quello di tom
cruise questo si chiama facebook ping ne
vedete un altro esempio in quest'altro
video qui avete due attrici che parlano
e il volto di un attrice viene
sostituito con quello dell'altra
l'effetto è tanto più realistico quanto
più i due soggetti sono somiglianti tra
loro in realtà è possibile anche fare
altro e possibile preservare l'identità
del soggetto come accade invece in
quest'altro caso è invece andare a
modificarne solamente l'espressione e la
voce
questi si chiamano appunto i deep fake
deep fake contiene le due parole di
planning e fake deep learning sta per
apprendimento profondo ed è il motore
dell'intelligenza artificiale
un computer proprio come un bambino
impara a risolvere problemi molto
complessi
dall'osservazione di moltissimi esempi
questa tecnologia ha permesso di
ottenere risultati eccezionali in
moltissimi campi e anche nella
generazione di video di immagini di alta
qualità
nei suoi termini di wi fi dalla
sensazione di qualcosa negativo in
realtà ci sono tanti aspetti positivi
del deep fake si pensi per esempio alla
campagna dal lancio della campagna
mal'aria namor in cui david beckham ha
potuto girare un video in nove lingue
diverse mantenendo il tono della sua
voce e con una perfetta sincronizzazione
tra il discorso è il movimento delle
labbra
questo apre un infinità di possibili
applicazioni nella produzione
cinematografica
in particolare pensate per esempio ad un
attore che può vivere una versione più
giovane o più anziani se stesso per
motivi scenografici senza doversi
sottoporre ad ore e ore di trucco
di poco tempo fa è il caso di uno spot
non girato di bruce willis in cui invece
è un attore russo a girare l'appunto
questo spot con le sue con i suoi
lineamenti con le sue movenze bruce
willis solamente dovuto dare
l'approvazione di poter utilizzare i
tratti somatici i suoi tratti somatici e
poi la tecnologia intelligenza
artificiale ha fatto il resto
e chiaro che ci sono anche aspetti
negativi dei deep fake id tech hanno
come primo esempio di zecca porno sono
comparsi nel 2017 sul sito reddit una
piccola sequenza video in cui lineamenti
della protagonista erano sostituiti con
quelli di un'attrice famosa c'è da dire
che attualmente sono proprio i dtec
porno essere quelli più diffusi su
internet
non solo con i depeche è possibile anche
creare false notizie e chiaro come una
fetta news a arricchita da un contenuto
multimediale quindi da video immagini
sia molto più efficace di un messaggio
di solo testo ma perché tutta questa
attenzione solo adesso perché se ne
parla adesso di manipolazione di
immagini manipolazione che c'è sempre
stata da quando è iniziata la fotografia
il vero punto non è tanto la
raffinatezza di questa tecnologia così
avanzata quanto la sua accessibilità
è molto facile creare un deep fake
ognuno di noi può farlo senza avere
particolari competenze
e questo è chiaramente qualcosa che
spaventa il fotoritocco diventa
democratico lo possono fare tutti e
quindi diciamo c'è bisogno anche un po
di capire possiamo difenderci da questo
possiamo rivelare un deep fake che tipo
di strumenti ci offre la tecnologia
io mi occupo proprio nella mia attività
di ricerca di sviluppare algoritmi per
la rivelazione di deep fake e più in
generale per la rivelazione di
manipolazioni nelle immagini e nei video
il mio lavoro che vi descriverò in
questo talk è molto simile a quello di
un investigatore che cerca le tracce
nella scena di un delitto
andiamo a cercare delle immagini dei
video tracce nascoste piccole
incongruenze che ci permettono di poter
capire se l'immagine o il video è stato
manipolato in particolare possiamo
analizzare due livelli di analisi ad un
primo livello
possiamo andare a vedere quelli che sono
i difetti visibili difetti che sono
anche si possono vedere anche occhio
nudo ma guardate l'immagine alle mie
spalle questa è un'immagine
completamente sintetica cioè generata al
calcolatore a parte notare qualche
incongruenza nello sfondo vedrete che è
molto realistica tuttavia gli orecchini
non sono perfettamente simmetrici anche
in quest altro caso
anche quest'altro caso potrete notare
come c'è un punto luminoso sull'orecchio
sinistro che non è presente
nell'orecchio destro
ancora altri tipi di artefatti che si
trovano soprattutto sulle tecniche di
prima generazione sono legate alla
riflessione della luce dalle corn e
vedete come per esempio in questa
immagine e soprattutto se consideriamo
uno zoom di questa immagine
questi punti luminosi nelle pupille non
siano perfettamente allineati non so se
riuscite a vedere bene diciamo bisogna
avere un occhio abbastanza attento e
questo accade anche in quest altra
immagine dove se facciamo uno zoom
noteremo questo tipo di inconsistenza
la cosa però non ci deve tranquillizzare
perché come se in qualche modo il
colpevole lasciasse tracce evidenti o
addirittura dicesse sono io il colpevole
quindi facessi una dichiarazione aperta
la tecnologia evolve rapidamente
e questi difetti man mano stanno
scomparendo
vi faccio vedere questi sono alcuni
esempi di tecnologie un po più recenti
dove davvero difficile riuscire a
trovare qualche piccola imperfezione
oltre al fatto di notare che non si
generano solamente volti ma anche posti
da sogno in cui si vorrebbe andare in
vacanza è che in realtà non esistono va
bene ma allora cosa possiamo fare per
gestire questa cosa cioè se in arte
fatto invisibile e l'immagine ci appare
perfetta che cosa possiamo fare
entriamo in un altro livello di analisi
che quello che ci permette di scoprire
gli artefatti invisibili quelli che non
si vedono ad occhio nudo ma ci sono
sempre facendo la nostra analogia è come
se non riusciamo a trovare un impronta
digitale e andiamo a cercare il dna
nella saliva che ti trovi nessun
mozzicone di sigaretta
il punto fondamentale da capire è che
ogni azione lascia una traccia anche
l'acquisizione di un'immagine da una
macchina fotografica anche quella lascia
una traccia lascia un'impronta digitale
all'interno della fotografia
questa non è una congiura dei governi
con i produttori hardware che vogliono
tracciare le nostre attività
semplicemente gli elementi del sensore
hanno delle piccole imperfezioni dovute
dal processo di manifattura e queste
imperfezioni creano un pattern un
pattern che presente in ognuna delle
immagini che scattiamo e che ovviamente
non si vede ma che ci permette di
identificare proprio la il dispositivo
che ha scattato quella stessa immagine e
allora possiamo utilizzare questo
pattern per scoprire eventuali
manipolazioni
in realtà il sistema anche ancora un po
più complesso ma facciamo riferimento a
questa sorta di
camera fingerprint come si chiama anche
quindi impronta digitale della
fotocamera e vi mostro un esempio
questa è un'immagine manipolata in
realtà non all'apparenza particolari
difetti ma sono immagini che abbiamo
scattato un po di tempo fa si è mia il
mio gruppo di ricerca
questa invece è l'immagine originale se
torniamo indietro notate che c'è una
persona che è stata inserita
nell'immagine che prima non c'era
quindi all'apparenza non ci accorgiamo
di niente ma se andiamo ad estrarre
l'impronta della fotocamera e noi
l'abbiamo fatto con algoritmo che
abbiamo sviluppato poco tempo fa
riusciamo ad individuare
un'inconsistenza
inconsistenza che può essere portata
ancora di più alla luce utilizzando
questa mappa vedete di localizzazione
della manipolazione un primo aspetto
importante è che questa estrazione di
impronta digitale è stata realizzata
proprio col deep learning quindi un uso
positivo di una tecnologia di questa
tecnologia così potente un altro aspetto
è che di fake anche sono caratterizzati
da impronte digitali artificiali che ci
permettono di poter discriminare quindi
le immagini pre generate da quelle reali
va bene però anche questo ancora non ci
deve troppo tranquillizzare perché
questo è un gioco in cui ci sono due
attori c'è l'attaccante e il difensore
c'è il criminale e il detective che
cercano in tutti i modi in qualche modo
di diventare sempre più esperti in
un'infinita corsa agli armamenti
quindi è vero che le tecniche di
rivelazione sono molto sofisticate e
permettono di rivelare anche questi
dettagli invisibili ma è anche vero che
le tecniche di sintesi diventano sempre
migliori e diventeranno senza difetti
senza difetti visibili ma forse anche
invisibili
va bene ma allora come fare come
affrontare il problema una possibilità è
quella di avere un approccio un po più
ampio un approccio più complesso in cui
si guarda la semantica il contesto in
cui si analizza
l'informazione non da sola ma
contestualmente per esempio supponete di
ascoltare qualcuno che fa un discorso
estremamente
complesso ma soprattutto che parla di un
evento catastrofico un evento
catastrofico male pressione le emozioni
del suo volto non corrispondono alla
gravità dell'evento
probabilmente c'è stata una
manipolazione audio e quindi le tecniche
possono essere appunto possono essere
realizzate in maniera un poco più
multimodale si dice quindi guardando sia
l'audio che il video contemporaneamente
magari includendo anche il testo questo
tipo di analisi e molto interessante
molto più complessa ma risponde davvero
al nostro problema supponiamo anche di
avere un deep fake detector che sia in
grado di rivelarci il 99 per cento di
false che si trovano su internet e
supponiamo che ci sia un acqua sul
vostro telefonino che vi assegna un
bollino rosso e un bollino verde ad ogni
immagine in video che scaricate va bene
allora vi fidereste di quest'app oppure
pensereste magari ma ma c'è un complotto
forse dietro c'è il governo debole
influenzarci o magari un colosso
industriale che vuole controllare
l'informazione e soprattutto chi è che
controlla il controllore chi è a capo di
questo ministero della verità
in realtà una pallottola d'argento che
colpisce deep fake non esiste non c'è
ancora sa tutto a noi alla nostra
capacità di leggere con attenzione le
informazioni che ci arriva che ci
arrivano di capire da quale fonte
arrivano dalla credibilità dalla storia
di questa fonte
e soprattutto è importante capire che
non è più vero e poi non possiamo più
dire vedere per credere quindi è
importante fare cosa osservare con
criticità osservare tutto con grande
spirito critico e con grande
consapevolezza perché alla fine la
pallottola d'argento siamo proprio noi
grazie
[Applauso]